Today,
I'm really delighted to introduce Oliver who,
Betty,
Dr. James Pressure,
who've written this,
uh,
this magnificent book,
very beautiful and informative.
Um,
I'll have her as a designer and journalist.
He was previously senior year design editor at National Geographic and Dr
Cheshire is at a university college London where he's a senior lecturer and
quantitative human geography and has a great interest in,
uh,
and using big data and visualization and the social sciences.
So,
uh,
please welcome.
Good
[inaudible]
hello.
And also hello to the wider Google audience.
Um,
it's,
it brings me great pleasure to be here,
um,
in,
in a number of ways.
Um,
especially being here in Boston because my brother Justin Uberti actually worked
here for a least a year.
I believe.
He worked at the Kirklin office and then came to Boston and is now back in
Kirkland and may be watching a,
so what's up bro?
We're going to talk about a number of things today.
We're going to be talking about data visualization.
Um,
we're also going to be talking about the partnership that James and I have as an
academic and as a graphic designer working on equal footing,
um,
to bring hard science to the public in these immersive data visualizations.
And we're going to reveal how we do that.
A bit of our process,
um,
you know,
on the backend processing data,
but then also all the labeling and front end work that goes to making these uh,
data sets,
um,
more accessible to the public.
Then you might find in the back of US scientific journal.
But first I want to talk a little bit about how we came to know each other and
that starts off with my work at national geographic.
Uh,
as a senior design editor.
Um,
I kind of came of age as data and big data was coming of age in the early two
thousands and found my cell,
even though it was in the design department,
eaves dropping a lot in the graphics department.
I was really interested in this idea of how we take data and Statistics and
start to visualize them.
And coming from a fine arts background.
I like to work with my hands a lot.
And we had this Dataset from a story out of the EPA and the study through Baylor
University where they were finding pharmaceuticals,
evidence of pharmaceuticals showing up in fish tissue,
uh,
in sites all around the country.
And to communicate this,
I thought we got to make a fish out of pills and not computer generated pills,
not sugar pills,
the actual medications that were found in this study.
So we fed up,
set up a photo studio,
a in a pharmacy after hours.
And,
uh,
I created this large mouth bass out of Prozac and anti Histamines,
the green and the yellow pills are the prozacs and you know,
that it was really,
I had no way of knowing what really pills the pharmacy was going to have in
stock.
So I showed up with this spreadsheet of permutations of how to keep the ratios
imbalanced depending on how many bills were available.
Um,
and then,
uh,
I got word of a set of research coming out of London and James Phd Project was
actually looking at surnames.
And the most popular surname's,
uh,
oh,
a huge database of surnames in the UK.
And I was wondering if he could help me create a map of the most popular
surnames in the United States and going back and forth over of course,
a month course of months.
Uh,
we produced this map which reveals the 25 most popular surnames in each state
that are sized by frequency and colored by,
uh,
country of origin,
approximately.
So you get pockets of Scandinavian and German ancestry in the Midwest,
uh,
Spanish surnames and rising up in the southern states,
pockets of French down in Louisiana.
And then of course up here in Massachusetts,
there's some Irish ancestry poking into the top 25 and to talk a little bit more
about this research and what led us onto our next collaboration,
bring James up
everyone.
Thanks for having us.
Um,
so essentially,
uh,
Oliver was the first designer I'd ever met or even spoken to,
I think at this point.
Um,
uh,
traditionally,
um,
you know,
as in the academic sphere don't often stick our heads out of our research
offices to speak to a broader audience.
And I really enjoyed working on this particular project where we were taking
kind of a large database of names and,
and,
and making them kind of easily accessible and Reuban this way.
And for someone it was just a phd student at the time.
Getting something in the National Geographic magazine was kind of a big,
big deal.
Alongside this,
I was,
um,
working on,
uh,
lots of maps and graphics about London.
So this was,
I'm not quite sure,
maybe a decade ago now,
um,
maybe slightly less than London was really entering a transition from being
quite a data poor city to a very data rich one.
So there's a lot of initiatives,
particularly in the UK but also,
um,
over here in the states about opening up data and making data freely available
to the public and for others to,
to use and make use of.
And so this was a bubbling away in the background on a research or a blog that I
was participating.
Uh,
uh,
I was contributing to making new forms of maps,
that kind of thing.
And it gained a lot of interest.
And,
um,
a couple of publishers approach me,
uh,
to,
to turn it into a book.
And it occurred to me that,
you know,
I'm good at making a s maps,
um,
that kind of are okay online and they look all right and research papers.
But I really needed a designer to,
to,
to take these and put them on the printed page and the options where you could
submit a draft manuscript to a publisher and use their in house designer or you
could work collaboratively with one as a coauthor throughout.
And that's why I approached Shawn liver as a recommendation or someone to
recommend really in the UK.
Um,
but he'd just gone freelance at that point and said that,
um,
you know,
I think he thought it was a lot further along with the project.
And then,
uh,
I actually was,
but he agreed to,
to work with me.
So this was that,
that was like,
this is our first book called London,
the information capital.
And we,
we,
uh,
did a whole series of data visualizations on that.
This one is looking at,
um,
24 hours of flights over UK,
air space.
And,
um,
uh,
just before we came out of the book,
we a Strava data,
the quantified self movement or that kind of stuff had just started.
So,
um,
we've got access to,
uh,
a bulk download from Strava.
It was still kind of a startup or a small startup at that point.
Um,
and we're able to map the flows of cyclists a into London across the rush hour
period.
And so I think,
you know,
if we look back and we think about what the biggest kind of contribution of that
book was and is,
it was this for the first time we were taking data that were being collected on
apps or that were already collected and that stopped behind,
uh,
firewalls and things like that.
We were taking it out and we were,
we were taking it to a wider audience.
And this was the first time people had seen this stuff,
um,
uh,
about undone or even any city.
Um,
and so that kind of got us thinking about some of the work that,
you know,
we can do together as a collaboration and how we can make a contribution.
And we've decided that,
you know,
the things we're really interested in is kind of taking a moment in time when
data is suddenly becoming available in unprecedented volumes,
capturing it in,
in data visualizations and then publishing it as books.
And it's not just about data visualization for its own sake.
You know,
we've all seen things online where there's um,
you know,
they kind of look called initially and then you look back at them or for a
second again eating actually,
what is that telling me?
That's not telling me anything or I don't really understand that.
You know,
network diagrams are a classic case,
you know,
social networks,
things like that.
Um,
so we're very much in the business of taking good design principles,
good cartographic principles and transforming them into compelling and
interesting data visualizations that can look quite traditional in many ways.
And you'll see that in some of the slides were showing.
So the,
the London book was a great success.
The publish obviously wanted us to do a second one and they were thinking about
Uk,
maybe another city,
something like that.
But Oliver,
um,
through his work at National Geographic was keen that we move spheres and
actually move into the animal because he'd noticed that they were at this kind
of technological moment when millions or billions of data points are now being
collected on,
on small sensors.
And for those,
if any of you worked with spatial data coordinates,
that kind of thing,
you know,
the great advantages,
the formats,
everything's exactly the same.
Whether it's a commuting cyclist in London in this map or some commuting
baboons,
uh,
in this map.
And this is a study where they had a gps loggers,
uh,
on a troop of baboons or most of a troop of baboons and they were sampling them
every second.
So they had their location every second over a three week period.
Um,
so that's a lot of data points.
And um,
you know,
the Nice thing about it was you get these kind of a daily movement.
So you can see this is where they start sleeping.
And then,
uh,
you know,
this is where they go out foraging and then they looped back to their sleeping
site.
That gives a nice kind of overall impression of their behavior.
But what the researchers were really interested in is,
uh,
have a boons make decisions on where they decided to go.
And so thanks to their data,
thanks to the fact they had data at second by second resolution.
You can zoom into particular moment.
And the moment we chose was the baboons running across this area of crop land
here.
They didn't like it.
They got harassed by local herders and farmers.
So it was kind of a big thing for the,
for the baboons and they to run across.
They didn't want to hang around.
And um,
we could then see that exact moment.
We could see,
um,
uh,
the,
some baboons run off one way,
some,
some run another way.
And the fact that also that the,
the,
the kind of go signal that the one that they all started running on was it was
led by juvenile and their mother,
not by an Alpha male or female.
And,
um,
you can see how,
uh,
you know,
different moments in time,
uh,
the,
the Boone's either decided to compromise where they want to go or they choose to
follow one or the other,
but it's a fairly democratic decision making process that the researchers had a
hunch about.
But,
um,
we're only really able to prove,
uh,
through,
um,
large crowd kind of data mining exercise to create these rules about when one
baboon goes one way,
how,
how do the others follow?
And this,
this study really represents,
I think that that transition from a researcher having to spend weeks in the
field in a,
in a,
uh,
hide or a truck just monitoring,
visually the behaviors of these animals to essentially be able to remotely
follow them and things like that.
And it's a transition that,
um,
I think it's probably been most profound in,
in looking at marine data in particular.
So this is,
um,
up until about,
I don't know,
maybe 20 years ago or even less,
was probably 20 years ago,
it's probably one the most comprehensive data sets on the distribution of whales
that existed.
And it's actually creative from a 19th century whaling logs.
So,
um,
in this case it was a,
because whales are a resource,
you know,
the city of Boston in particular was,
uh,
all the areas around here were particularly dependent on wailing.
You know,
you want us to know where the whales,
where and how you,
how many you've caught because it was a century in auditing exercise and,
um,
a guy called towns and went through and,
uh,
manually mapped each of the locations of the approximate locations of where
whales were killed by species.
And,
um,
you get this distribution map where you get different species of whale,
uh,
different times of years appearing.
And this liked a number of examples in the kind of animal kingdom is an example
of where you're mapping where the animals have died essentially.
Um,
it's uh,
not when they're living,
but when they've been killed.
Um,
you're managing a resource,
you're not managing a kind of environment,
you're not managing an ecosystem.
And
that kind of lead researchers in the 60s on was to start developing their own
mini sensors to monitor animal movement and behaviors.
So this is one of the first,
uh,
bio logging,
devices that was created.
It was a developed by a guy called Rory Wilson,
who's at the University of a Swanzi.
And uh,
you can see here it's kind of a syringe that he's pushed a spring in.
This is a piece of cork.
And on that piece of cork,
he,
he had a bit of magnesium that was,
was,
uh,
burning,
when it came into contact with water and they strapped it to the front of
Penguins.
And when the penguin was swimming,
depending on the speed it was going,
it would push that cork in a kind of up that syringe and the magnesium wood
burner align on it.
And you'd see,
uh,
how fast the at the animal swimming.
No one had done this before.
And you know,
even with this kind of somewhat clumsy device on the front of them,
you know,
he discovered that the birds were swimming faster and further than than we
thought.
Jump forward to the present day.
This is what Rory is.
Lab now looks like.
It's kind of a mission control for the animal data.
Here we have,
um,
a couple of minutes of data from a circling vulture that they've attached a
attack too.
So you can see there's all kinds of different,
uh,
sensors that are crammed into the small device.
Now.
Accelerometers,
magnetometers,
gps.
And so this is kind of like a feed of information they have about the bird
spiraling,
a behavior,
looking at turbulence over the wings and that kind of thing.
So we really wanted to,
to kind of get to grasp,
uh,
get to grips with the data and see if we can visualize it in an interesting way.
How do you take back,
which isn't necessarily a,
um,
you know,
uh,
user friendly version of,
of,
of a data feed.
How do you,
how do you make that into something that looks a bit like this where you've
actually just extracted a small sample of that data are really interesting part
of it just for a few seconds of a voucher flight and you've,
uh,
looked at the air temperature outside,
which is one of the things that,
that we're mapping here.
Um,
and you can really see how,
uh,
the sensors detecting these very tiny kind of fluctuations Petia patients and in
a bird behavior and they can start looking and understanding of that to see how
things are,
how the animal behaves and how it accounts for different things.
So that's the journey.
That's the journey we're on here.
And there's some really remarkable technology.
So we've got Rorys,
uh,
really high resolution,
magnetometers,
accelerometers and things like that,
but he's trying to put on birds.
And then we've also got tags that,
um,
you know,
this is probably the largest tag that we've,
uh,
we kind of feature in the book.
It's about the size of a computer mouse.
Um,
that thing is,
is capable of collecting something like 62 gigabytes of data and a 12 hour time
period,
um,
about one way or so.
Um,
in here there's a couple of little attachments where they stick suction cups,
you know,
same thing.
You did attach a sat nav to a car window with,
they creep up behind the whale with this thing on a long pole and then they kind
of just flipped the pole down and it hits the back of the whale and uh,
sticks on.
And then after about 12 hours it would drop off and float to the surface with
all this data.
And that,
that these are kind of passive sensors.
They have active ones too,
but they're passive in the sense that they are using the whales sonar to,
uh,
detect what the way it is doing.
So when whales of toothed whales in particular hump,
they emit some sonar that bounces back from uh,
their environment and just as the whale is detecting the bounce back,
uh,
centers,
able to take that as well.
And we have the exact moment.
This is over a five second period,
um,
when,
uh,
a tooth,
well,
it is hunting at a very small fish.
So this is a fish that's maybe this big and just from the,
so nice,
a bit tricky to see here,
but you can see that there's these signatures here and this is stuff bouncing.
This is the reflection coming back from the particular fish that he's,
that he's after.
So,
uh,
each,
um,
the winter of each of these boxes,
columns here is the,
uh,
time between,
buses.
So the whale starts off clicking.
So it will let,
let off a click and wait some milliseconds before the next one comes back.
A few milliseconds for the next one comes back.
And it kind of a coarse resolution.
It realizes there's a fish here,
this is something I'm interested in.
And then it zooms in a bit on the fish and then uh,
for a couple of seconds,
it then does this buzz,
which is a really high resolution noise.
And then this is the signature and we get every moment that the fish is getting
closer and closer.
The whales heads here.
So this is kind of distance so you can see the fish is getting closer to the
whale.
And then,
um,
this is a point,
see this is where the fish realizes that it's possibly lunch and it coils up and
we kind of springs off to try and swim away.
So you get this kind of slightly more scattered,
uh,
impression from the sonar.
I here and then you get it to swimming off in this direction and then it
completely disappears.
Um,
cause the good news for the fish is the fish essentially just did that.
Uh,
and as soon as the fish moves to one side,
the whale can't see it anymore cause that,
so in our beam is pretty,
it's pretty narrow field of view.
So the worst thing you can do if you're being chased by a wireless to try and
out swim it,
um,
you just need to move to one side,
and,
and it loses you.
So
we kind of have information about the,
how the,
the whales are feeding about their particular ecology,
but we're also using animals to,
um,
do some ocean sensing for ourselves.
So these are kind of like sent animals sentinels if you like.
And this is one of our favorite examples really,
that,
that shows some of the kind of processes that were going through.
So this is a sensor.
It's actually quite large,
um,
rebut,
but they get a little bit bigger than this.
It's about this size actually looking at stuff to the head of a seal.
And it detects information about ocean temperature,
salinity,
that kind of thing,
not for ecologist,
but for oceanographers who want to know what's going on in the world's oceans.
And there's hundreds of these seals swimming round and talk to occur.
And this is kind of the raw feed of data that comes back or at least some
indication of their location.
And this to me was,
it was kind of the first graphic raw graphic I produced and it really captured
everything we were trying to show for the book.
It's one of these graphics that you think,
wow,
that's a big hairball of data.
That's really interesting.
What surprised me really was um,
all of those kind of initial take on it.
So um,
here we have the big hairball and I thought this would be the main kind of
feature story about these particular sensitive particular animals I've sent.
I sent that previous image to,
to Oliver.
He then puts it in a kind of initial draft layout.
This is the first indicator,
you know,
lay out that we came out with and you'll see that,
that his instinct is to remove all the color and all that kind of clutter and
just focus on one individual track one individual story.
That's what we want to show within this big hairball.
And it's a bit like this in nature documentaries,
if you ever watch a nature documentary,
they're not looking at a whole colony of Gannets,
you know,
those zoom in on one particular breeding pair or something like that.
It's because people can understand that and relate to it.
And this is essentially what we're trying to do here.
So this is a fictitious track that's just been drawn on,
but we start looking through the hairball to find one that we've,
we've particularly thought was representative and we settled on Rudolf who,
uh,
is a,
an elephant seal that was tagged for a year or more actually,
I think a couple of years.
Uh,
and we actually track him a swimming along the Antarctic peninsula hauling out
here on some cis and then swimming back across towards the Falkland Islands.
And around there,
one story that we then started thinking,
well,
this is really interesting,
but it's a bit of a blank canvas still.
We've got the journey,
but what's he encountering?
What kind of terrain is there?
Um,
what's,
what's going on in the water beneath him?
So we spent a lot of time working on um,
terrain mapping techniques and we'll talk briefly about this in a second.
Uh,
that really captures,
you know,
the ocean floor as it as,
as it is.
So you can see the deep trenches is swimming over.
Um,
the cit is encountering and really getting to grips with that single narrative.
You'll see that we have the hairball still here,
but it's actually been shrunk down to quite a small part of the double page
spread.
Um,
cause we want it to,
to focus in on that individual.
And what's more,
we actually gave Rudolph two spreads in the book,
which is quite privileged.
Not many animals get,
uh,
two double page spreads because actually we were interested too in the data that
he was able to collect about ocean temperature.
So that particular transect,
uh,
is uh,
strung across the page here.
The black line is the depths that,
uh,
he's diving too.
Now,
I thought this was a glitch on the sensor,
but this line here is a thousand meters down.
So at that point you break some thousand meters underwater.
And I thought that was a mistake,
but actually seals are capable of,
they regularly dive to those kinds of depths.
Um,
and that's why they're great ocean monitors because as they're diving down,
they're collecting all these measurements and you get a temperature gradient
here of,
of,
of data.
You can kind of see how,
uh,
you know,
we've gone from that kind of initial,
um,
hairball,
which looked a bit like this as well with the contextual data.
These are kind of individual,
uh,
animal types,
to,
to a much kind of cleaner impression of what's going on.
Um,
so really a lot of what we do is kind of a data reduction exercise.
You know,
we talked about big data,
but we're actually in the business of reducing as much of the data as we can to
get kind of insight or intelligence.
I guess
for,
for another part of this story,
it was really important to get that contextual information.
So I mentioned the sea floor that we were interested in for Rudolph,
but if your,
um,
a burden you're flying,
actually that doesn't make much difference.
What you're interested in is the kind of medium that you're passing through.
And that's,
that's air.
Uh,
that's the winds you're encountering.
So I'm sure many of you have seen,
um,
this really excellent,
uh,
whether visualization,
um,
uh,
called Earth Dot nullschool.
Um,
you know,
it's one of the first visualization,
kind of as a,
as a cartographer that really made the cartographic community kind of sit up and
think actually computer scientists kind of know what they're doing sometimes
when it comes to data visualization and you know,
they're capable of creating these kinds of graphics.
So it kind of inspired by that.
Um,
uh,
I thought we really need to show wind global wind patterns for a story we've got
about albatrosses.
So,
um,
here is,
uh,
something I generated.
Um,
um,
this is,
uh,
does anyone use our,
here are steps.
I did this in our,
probably one of my proudest visualizations I've ever done in,
in our,
um,
which captured the wind conditions are approximately during the period that we
were interested in is modeled data.
It's not actual,
uh,
they have a few readings,
but of course they have to interpolate it.
But you can basically the Antarctica,
this is Antarctica and all the winds rushing off.
And the reason this was so important was it brought to life this story about
these migrating these wandering albatrosses that go all the way around a
Antarctica.
And in particular there's this point of no return,
which these curricula and island here and essentially because of the way that
the winds are kind of whipping round the continent,
it's easier for a bird to fly all the way round than to try and turn back,
uh,
to the,
to,
to the breeding colony.
So you can see here this,
this guy kind of made it and then turn back was this one carried on all the way
around because they needed the tailwinds to help them.
And the researchers hadn't actually mapped the wind on to their data or their
data onto the wind.
So,
um,
this was something that,
you know,
we're quite pleased with because it really brought to life some of the,
the,
the importance of the country,
the context that the animals are moving through.
And that's often overlooked,
particularly by the researchers who are more concerned about the,
you know,
the specifics of their data.
And then just the final example of context,
um,
that,
that we can now do.
And,
um,
it is,
you know,
thanks to satellite imagery and,
and remotely remotely sense technology.
You can actually map the data onto the conditions that the animal was really
experiencing at that time.
So this is a story about snowy owls in the Great Lakes and how they,
um,
uh,
spend time,
over the winter.
And how thanks to tracking technology,
the researchers,
um,
notice that the,
the,
the birds were spending a lot of time or on lakes on the Great Lakes and
actually discovered that they were floating on ice,
um,
and,
and hunting a wild fowl.
And you know,
if we'd used our kind of standard satellite imagery basement for this,
you know,
that was probably taken in the summer or something like that.
All these blue circles,
which are kind of moments when the bird of particular hours spent spent time
drifting on ice would have been in,
in,
in water.
They wouldn't have been on ice.
So thanks to the NASA motor symmetry,
we're,
we were able to get,
again,
approximate date.
This was over a month long period.
We had this data.
So we selected one day in that month and we were able to kind of line up the
bird information with the actual ice information,
which,
um,
you know,
we,
we often people kind of overlook that.
But from a kind of a,
for a very detailed perspective,
that's quite important for us to be able to do that.
And it's really demonstrative of a transition from kind of like a data poor
environment,
a very data rich one that the satellites have been able to give us.
Um,
so I had no,
to all of announced to a bit more about some of our design process
in both of our books.
Uh,
a theme that emerges to us,
uh,
nearly every day when we're working two years at a time on a,
on,
on a book books that we could have never done these books by ourself.
Like I couldn't have produced this book without James.
His ability to process huge datasets and his gis expertise.
And it's just general knowledge of cartography,
the and computer programming,
writing custom scripts that,
that produce those wind patterns.
What I like to bring to the table besides the journalistic storytelling
perspective,
is the design,
that topography and a big part of helping a reader engage with these maps and
pool away a story is labeling.
And I mean every time we make a book we have to decide these basic principles of
what does a road look like in our map.
How do we enable a country versus a bay versus the actual animals behavior and
tracks?
How do we create a hierarchy a that lets the reader zero in on what they want to
know as quickly as possible.
So I'm going to talk through one example.
I live in Los Angeles and one of my favorite stories in the book and uh,
the story of conservation that feels most urgent to me is about p 22 in the
mountain lions of Angeles.
I lived near Griffith Park.
Uh,
p 22 is a bit of an English tutor,
uh,
in Hollywood right now.
He's got his own Twitter account.
You can get tee shirts with his likeness on him.
Um,
this is an incredible photograph by Steve Winter.
He shot this for National Geographic,
uh,
using camera traps.
And,
uh,
the problem that the mountain lions in,
in southern California region are facing is that they're effectively marooned on
genetic islands by the freeways.
These freeways are eight,
10,
late lanes long,
uh,
in the Santa Monica Mountains is one population p 20 to escape out of Santa
Monica is and got to Griffith Park where he lives by himself.
But the chances of him getting back to the Santa Monica's to meet with another
female are slim.
And even then,
he still mating within his own gene pool.
So He's got a,
uh,
the prognosis for,
for his,
uh,
genetics is not very good.
Um,
down in the Santa Ana mountains.
you know,
south of La Towards Orange County on the way to San Diego was another population
of mountain lions.
And in both cases,
they really need an escape hatch.
They need a vegetated bridge that you start to see in some other countries and
Canada,
Slovenia,
some countries are building these forest.
It overpasses to allow the free movement of wildlife.
There's a proposal has been greenlighted to help mountain lions from [inaudible]
family up in the Santa Monica Mountains get across the one on one,
but down in the Santa Ana's,
uh,
that really hasn't,
that proposal hasn't taken hold.
And so I really wanted to zero in on that other Santa Ana population.
This is a about 15 years of mountain lion tracking in southern California in the
Santa Ana mountains.
Um,
and as we showed with the seals,
if you just plot the data that comes out of the sensors,
uh,
it doesn't mean a whole lot.
So how can we start establishing context to bring the story to life for readers?
One thing we want to do is you start wanting to lay in the terrain that the
mountain lions are passing through.
So we've got digital elevation models of the mountain ranges along the coast.
And it was important to me that this book have,
uh,
have,
come together as an ensemble and just have a color Palette and a in a visual
field that tied all these different maps or all these different parts of the
world,
all these different species and technologies together.
And again,
coming from a fine arts background,
I wanted to take these dms a little bit further.
Uh,
visually.
And there's a technique you were in an art school called stippling.
If you want to render an object,
the shadowed areas,
you can just draw a lot of dots.
And in the lighter highlighted areas,
draw fewer dots.
So working together with James Number of iterations,
he wrote a custom script,
a w where he could essentially take digital elevation model,
run it through this and put lots of little dots on a stippling in the dark
shadow areas of the mountain and fewer dots in the lower lying flat areas.
And so you end up getting an output looking like this,
which we used on every,
uh,
land based map throughout the book.
And that same technique is what gives the texture to the bothy mitre you saw in
the seal map near Antarctica.
But then,
uh,
there's a lot of human environments that the mountain lions are interacting
with.
Um,
and you know,
we need to start identifying them.
So this is me at the very beginning of the book.
Before we even start producing a lot of these maps.
I'm coming up with a typographic Palette,
a series of three fonts that we can use interchangeably,
um,
to,
you know,
how do we enable the waters,
how do we label the city's a series of symbols a we can use to label,
um,
mortality events or when a wolf kills an animal.
And then,
you know,
building a template,
an illustrator that has a hierarchy broken out so we can easily turn on and turn
off and organize all of this contextual information.
And so then James starts sending the exports.
This is drainage in southern California and most of this is all these green
little streams and,
and temporary drainage's or seasonal drainage's or are hugely irrelevant.
So it's an enormous,
um,
data cleaning chore to Start Turning this into something that doesn't make your
eyes bleed.
And then you started throwing in the road networks.
Now this is really where the story of the human environment meets the story of
the animal behavior.
So this is going to be what I want to highlight in my map more than,
uh,
the drainage.
And we see we've overlaid this over the stippling and he's in our initial
drafts.
You start to get something like this,
and I've got all of the,
uh,
data points you saw earlier and I just grade them back hoe or them darker gray
for male lions and lighter gray for female lions.
And then we started talking with the researcher and thinking,
can we pull out five individuals that maybe show different behaviors?
Um,
for instance,
the females don't have a large dispersal range.
The female mountain lions tend to stay close to where they were born and they
continue to raise their cubs.
Whereas you get mountain lions who,
uh,
the male mountain lions who need to disperse out for a number of reasons.
One being that they will be killed or eaten by the older male mountain lions if
they don't strike out and find their own territory.
So there's this one,
intrepid mountain lion,
a m 56,
who leaves the Santa Ana's near Camp Pendleton appear and then comes down along
the coast and ocean side and cuts up along the Santa Margarita River and comes
over and is the only documented,
uh,
you know,
15 to 17 years,
a mountain line that's crossed a west to east across I 15.
So he gets across and you think he's home free.
He's got this unbroken chain of wilderness,
essentially all the way down into Mexico.
Uh,
but he comes down here into the hot tub,
pool valley,
um,
praise on a farmers or ranchers,
sheep.
The farmer gets a,
uh,
depredation permit and uh,
and 56 was shot.
So,
uh,
it's,
the challenge is not just getting across but getting across in living long
enough to pass on your genes.
But again,
this wasn't really doing it for me.
The color scheme is a bit luxurious.
Uh,
all this success of,
um,
data points in the background of the male and female lions,
is really making harder to,
as a reader connect with the individual stories.
So I cleaned out all of that other data from all the other lions and just zoomed
in and use bright highlight colors to pull out the individual stories and,
uh,
you know,
in the hierarchy,
a subdued everything else.
Now this is an ongoing conservation issue and it's a,
it's a story of maybe what we did wrong,
right?
The,
the mountain lions are,
uh,
a signal.
They tell us that maybe we've gone too far.
There are freeways and our infrastructure is greater barrier than we had
previously imagined.
And we need to now take steps like creating vegetated brains,
bridges to kind of step backward and give the wildlife a chance to,
uh,
live in proximity to humans.
But over in Kenya,
you know,
we're,
the infrastructure hasn't,
uh,
you know,
been so,
uh,
permanently in fixed on our landscape.
They're taking proactive measures.
It's one of the first places a on a planet where they're developing your
infrastructure with wildlife in mind.
When the great pleasures of this book for me was to go over to Kenya and work
with save the elephants.
And they allowed me to join a coloring expedition in Savo National Park.
We're recently a major railway,
had been built from Nairobi and the center of the country to Mombasa on the
coast.
And this railway high speed railway,
um,
bisects Sabo national park,
right through elephant migration corridors.
But through,
say the elephants lobbying efforts and working with a number of local
organizations,
they were able to get the construction company to install these underpasses,
uh,
points throughout the entire railway.
It's an elevated railway and they've got these,
uh,
tunnels underneath.
But what they didn't know was which of these many underpasses elephants were
most likely to use.
And if they could figure out which ones they were going to use,
then they could target their conservation efforts and anti poaching efforts to
those corridors.
So we coward.
I was there.
10 elephants,
five male,
five female,
um,
they were these big,
bulky,
um,
belts around their neck with a,
with a counterweight on the bottom and a gps device on the top.
It's elephants are pretty rough on these devices and they'll slam him up against
the things they have to be pretty sturdy.
And then,
uh,
this is just a zoom in on a larger map that we have in the book to show what
happened after 30 days of being collared.
And a key theme in this book is that the animals aren't these furry robots out
there in the world following a Westworld type loop.
They make individual decisions all the time and a couple of those individual
decisions,
even within a species,
um,
come out on this book.
So after being colored,
uh,
there's this one you see here in red,
you know,
she was up coward up here off the top of the map.
And anytime you have to subdue an animal and a color,
it's a little bit traumatic for the animal that they incredibly can shoot a dart
from the helicopter land,
run over,
take all their measurements,
a pour water on the animal,
keep it's breathing airway open,
uh,
attach to the collar and then inject a antidote that wakes the animal back up
all within about 10 to 12 minutes.
I couldn't believe I was watching this right in front of me.
But after there's 12 minutes,
the animal wakes up and my Niani here,
the red mine,
she comes rushing down and goes right to the humans that she trusts here by the
Kenyan Wildlife Service field training school.
And for about 30 days,
just hung around outside the ranger school cause she knew she was safe there.
Uh,
a couple other ones just continued doing what they do and going over to some of
the rivers where they like to drink.
And this guy,
Rick Kinga down here,
he was using,
he was the first one,
uh,
within 24 hours of being coward to use one of the underpasses and make his way
up here and back and down.
And,
um,
you know,
within a month he was just crossing here on a regular basis.
Okay.
And here you get a sense of both sides.
So this is the railway berm under construction as we're flying in and Sabo,
uh,
east over here in Sabah West.
Um,
they're planning to turn this two lane road into a multilane four or five,
six lane road.
So that's gonna be another barrier for the elephants to get across.
But again,
with proactive planning,
they can build their infrastructure with wildlife in mind.
It's just give you a sense of,
uh,
how quickly they can get in there and,
and,
uh,
color the elephants.
And then,
uh,
the moment when one of them wakes up.
Okay.
Save the elephants.
Wasn't too thrilled.
The,
uh,
some rangers spray painted a number on the side of the elephant,
but I guess that makes it easier when they were doing their aerial surveys to
see where,
uh,
the ones they had collared where,
but anyway,
that's one of the hopeful stories in the book of using this of science
research,
technology ecology and data visualization to make sure that in humans and
animals can coexist.
I'm looking forward.
Okay.
Did you often have to deal with a untrustworthy data?
What do you mean by untrustworthy?
Like from different,
uh,
data sample from different places and maybe you had to clean it up or just the,
it just didn't seem like it was,
it's actually a reasonable,
this is it.
So it's,
it's an interesting debate actually within the community.
Um,
about what you do with bad data.
uh,
because I was,
you know,
there's a bit of a trend or perceived trends of academia,
academic life where you have to be always reporting positive results and
negative stuff's useful as well.
And this really applies to at what stage you share your data.
So are you sharing date data that um,
what collects it,
you know,
the raw data collected on the device or do you,
do you share stuff that's come through a data cleaning process?
So we were getting data from all stages of that process.
Now if some stuff was completely off,
like,
you know,
gps point was a thousand kilometers away or whatever,
then then that,
um,
you know,
there was a,
a kind of,
I did a basic cleaning operation,
which often was a status of data reduction thing where you,
you,
you run across and say,
why would this,
there's no way an animal when a thousand kilometers in an hour or something like
that.
Um,
but,
but our
approach has always been to try and show as much of the data as possible without
doing too much with it.
And now there's,
there's whole
studies on how you interpolate between data points and all that kind of stuff.
Um,
but we tried to stay out of that as much as possible and just showed specific
that the kind of raw data as best we can because if,
if,
if a data set's been interpolated or someone's done some modeling on it,
then you've got to kind of explain that process as well as the reader,
which we didn't want to do.
So the answer is yes,
the,
the word messy data points,
but,
um,
fewer than I expected actually given the technologies that were involved,
I think.
Yeah.
Is there a dream Dataset or dream datasets that you haven't worked with yet that
you'd really like to?
We get,
we get asked that question a lot.
Specific to that boy or just in general on,
on the next future project.
You're the experts.
Okay.
Uh,
we have a third book in the works.
I just don't know how much we want to talk about this stuff.
I mean,
I think that the,
the dream,
so,
so specific to this,
the,
that researchers are after and they're there probably a couple of years away
from getting his interaction social.
So we've got the example,
we have some aunts that they put QR codes on the backs of and use high
resolution cameras to track and it's in these particular colonies.
Um,
that was our largest dataset because they were getting interactions.
uh,
and they're planning to,
to,
to the,
there's a group to clean in,
in Germany with the Max Planck Institute for mythology that are planning to
deploy enough sentences that you get interact both between animals and Predator,
prey relationships and human.
So as soon as you start bringing interactions in,
it gets the dataset explodes.
And so that's something that we're not quite at that stage yet.
Um,
but that's something I think just to get our heads around.
That would be cool.
Um,
and then I think just building on the only talked briefly,
but when we're getting to the point where animals are backing each other up now
with their data as well.
So
there's a story out of Monterey Bay Aquarium.
We,
we have a series of graphics in here on the Sea otters off California and how
they were,
we thought we were thought to be extinct until a small population was discovered
back in the 30s and protected and now they've rebounded.
And the Monterey Bay aquarium is doing all sorts of conservation efforts and
tracking to manage that population.
And they're about to release,
if not to have an already released it this year.
That's um,
program called [inaudible].
But I really wanted to get into the book,
but the technology,
Justin wasn't deployed yet by the time we had to publish.
And net is that exact thing.
It's this idea of getting the social behavior and interactions between mating
males and resident females and how as an entire population they're working
together and between buoys that whenever the auditors pass by the buoys,
they offload their data to,
to a storage.
Um,
and then when the honor is passed by the each other,
they offload their data to the sensors on each honor.
Um,
so in case anything happens to the odder,
uh,
their data isn't lost forever.
So that's really the frontier.
That was awesome.
Thanks for being here.
My question is,
uh,
how much do you know about the story before you start the visualization process?
Or do you look at a big Dataset and figuring out what's the right story to tell
based off this?
How much do you talk to the researchers beforehand?
The research,
this book
about animals,
but it's really about the researchers who study them.
I mean,
they were
so kind to sometimes welcome us into their homes in Ohio or in Nairobi.
I'm James went out in the North Atlantic with killer whale researchers.
Um,
they worked with us start to finish.
we would usually do initial interviews to try and get a sense of maybe we'd
heard about their research in a scientific journal and then we reached out to
them,
told them what we were doing,
and then we'd do initial to figure out,
okay,
what,
what could be cool to visualize?
What are some of your favorite stories?
What are your,
some of your favorite individuals who have surprised you with unique behaviors
and then once they shared our data,
we do initial plots and it was always a back and forth.
Okay,
are we on the right track?
Yes,
this looks good.
And then at the end,
when I'm coming from National Geographic I,
my habit as a designer is to to build the visuals first and then we write the
story last to fill in the space that the visuals have allotted for the text.
And so once we had finished the layout and draft of the story,
then we send it back to him for a final review.
Corrections.
Yeah,
just I think that was a slightly different,
that was a difference in process for the London Book of most of that was in my
head to start with in a sense that I'd researched the city,
I knew what was going on,
so I knew that these would be the stories I wanted to tell.
Whereas this was much more iterative.
It was like,
Oh,
you show the research that the graphic we've done.
And they were like,
oh,
well that's,
we didn't think of it like that or that's more interesting and you'd go back to
the drawing board.
So we have no emotions.
We're biologists were not,
I mean geographer designer,
but you know,
our combined skill sets to allow us to help scientists,
you know,
share their research more widely.
And also in some cases we surprise them with what we were able to reveal about
what their animals were doing.
I just want to make one more point to tack onto that.
And is that like,
that is really for you here at Google and people who work with data and have
these incredible skills.
Um,
that's the beauty of this animal tracking revolution is then you don't have to
be a biologist to get involved in conservation.
These scientists all over the planet,
uh,
they,
they're inundated with data like a week long study could inundate them with
millions of data points.
Um,
so they really need people to help,
you know,
crunch the data and,
and interpreted.
Um,
has either of you specifically studied cartography or worked with any
cartographers?
Obviously National Geographic for example,
has a huge cartography department and a,
or is it more just kind of more general graphic design principles that you work
from?
So I've got no formal concert graphic training that's,
so I did joke fee degree and then uh,
uh,
fee phd,
but none of it was ready cuts over I think.
Well,
what's interesting,
I mean the u s is kind of ahead of this ahead of the UK in many ways is that,
um,
there's a transition.
I think that the,
you know,
I teach cartography to students,
but I call it a data visualization.
Um,
because you know,
they get paid five times as much for it if they put that on their CV for one
thing.
And secondly,
um,
that there's a lot more to it.
I mean there's,
there's,
there's the good stuff about how you convey information to people and the
standardization of things and like that visual hierarchy of labels Oliver was
talking about when that's really important.
But increasingly,
you know,
to make maps,
you need to have this broader data science e type background because that's
where the action is.
It's not where people,
people aren't having to map new areas of the world,
you know,
for the first time,
the,
the frontier is really ever in these databases that are being distracted.
Is that something,
I'm really a kind of lobby for within this the cards graphic community,
uh,
back in the UK at least to try and get more people with programming experience
to learn a bit about cartography and not make the same mistakes,
but also people who've got cartographic training to learn a bit about
programming so they can
cut,
you know,
make the efficiency savings.
We've been able to make it in this
and absolutely.
I mean by Osmosis working in national geographic for a decade,
I was immersed in their cartographic practices.
Um,
labeling styles.
They have proprietary fonts they use.
Um,
but you know,
there are things like,
okay,
you can use Italics for physical features or use a different sizes of a sand
Sarah for sitting labels.
And a lot of that was definitely informing.
Um,
my thought process when I said about the build this type of graphic Palette.
and,
uh,
we actually hired one of my former colleagues in the cartography department to
be a map editor.
So after we produced 50 some maps,
um,
he vetted all of them,
and in many,
many cases spotted things that I never would have picked up on my own,
such as I had a road crossing the Niger River in Mali.
And in fact,
there's a ferry that takes you across there and on the road.
So,
um,
all right,
well,
thanks again guys.
[inaudible].